here's the problem right here
from the new york post
hollywood stars are fleeing to austin
amid the coven 19 pandemic and i warned
y'all this would happen
when there's that comic of joe rogan and
he's got his little pool bag you know
whatever roller bag and he's walking
from california texas and the bag says
liberal policies have been a fanny pack
by the way and there's it says liberal
policies on it and there's a cowboy
saying like hey hold on there mister why
don't you leave that where you got it
everyone's like yeah but is joe rogan
really going to be bringing these
policies with him he may be fairly like
lefty in a lot of ways but he's very
anti-authoritarian
and he has staff
and he is going to run a business like
with with you know he's got he's got his
comedy uh aspirations he wants to he
wants
started a club there you go gotta hire
people so what's gonna happen the people
from the industry in california are
gonna be like well joe rogan's hiring i
guess i'll go out there and those are
rational people they're not far lefties
but they're a little lefty they'll
probably still vote democrat and then
the rest of the hollywood stars are
gonna be like did you hear that elon
musk and and and uh you know and and uh
all of these really fun and amazing
people are moving to austin i should go
there too and i've got a bunch of
hollywood celebrities being like
austin's the place to be and guess what
they're going to bring all their staff
and they're going to bring all their
lefty politics that's right because the
because the person who makes 50 000 a
year carrying the the the coattails of
some hollywood celebrity is not going to
be conservative they're going to be like
uh uh to those according to their needs
or whatever that's what they're going to
be advocating for
so they're all going to come and taxes
is going to help
well maybe i think i i definitely think
so that's the case okay so if that's the
case uh so the new yorkers are flying to
florida we've seen that
uh californians are fleeing to texas
that's happening so
where the hell are we supposed to go
west virginia west virginia texas
tennessee kentucky almost in texas again
i mean tennessee kentucky west virginia
i know louisville is uh
has some interesting stuff going on
where's that louisville yeah louisville
louisville i don't even know i don't
know i don't even know was like what's
that what is that yeah i don't know
good point i don't even know louisville
actually that's in colorado so yeah let
me just pretend i got that mixed up
uh nashville here is doing pretty pretty
good right you know yeah you've got uh
daily wires out there yeah yeah see
everybody you want to visit it was it
was so reactive for everybody to be like
texas
and i'm like that's like a trope about
texas being this like free and very red
state it's like it was almost 50 50 this
past couple past couple elections and
austin is deep blue and it's attracting
all of the hipsters it's it's been since
south by southwest as far as i can
remember it's very hipster well austin
has been for a long time what about like
maybe eastern montana
oh oh no no no
montana wyoming 100 oh yeah you want to
go live in the middle of nowhere and
rough it and figure it out for yourself
do it do it you can do that i think
bozeman might be a little blue though
yeah yeah that's why i'm saying eastern
montana
yeah i've driven through there it's
awesome it's beautiful you can't even
get cell service today i'm saying look
so we we were
we didn't want to move to a place where
we're going to get the influx of the the
progressive faux activists i don't even
think it's fair to call the hollywood
star's leftists that's unfair to
leftists
it is
like if if i can sit here and have a
conversation with an actual communist
who believes in communism and genuinely
believes in communism i can respect them
actually standing up and being honest
these hollywood even though i disagree
with them the hollywood stars they don't
believe in anything
they're just saying they're like
so we're looking at places they're
opportunists absolutely they're like
whatever whatever the the corporations
want me to say so they pay me their
models glorified models they're
marketing it's marketing
they're literally marketing tools for
movies and for shows so of course
they're going to side with corporate
america and say whatever they think will
sell more doesn't mean that they don't
know stuff some of them are probably
incredibly educated well sure james
woods yeah you get you get the little
mean though you know your job is to keep
your mouth shut though so if they are if
they do know what's going on they will
get ostracized if they speak up
to me basically i stopped getting called
back when they stopped my youtube videos
2007. that was rough look we were trying
to find a place where we can get away
from the cities have space and
you know expand and we were in the
philly area and it was it was nuts it
was one of the worst states for
restrictions and they told us like in
march don't go outside anymore unless
you have no choice they were like don't
walk around with people and we were like
this is crazy that's insane but we look
at texas and i'm like i can see what's
going to happen in texas i can see
what's going to happen with these
hollywood california arizona colorado
they're all going to keep coming in and
then there you go you end up with
hipster blue state now west virginia's
losing people people are because there's
a there there's this phenomenon that's
really fascinating even in red states
urban centers tend to be blue for some
reason so even in west virginia you have
blue areas the people who are there
there's an article i was writing in the
ap and they were this woman was like i'm
a teacher and this is horrible the state
is terrible i'm leaving i'm going to
texas
and i was like yes
get out of here west virginia man you've
got a lot of opportunity we were looking
at some small dying towns i was like
wouldn't it be cool if we went to an
area that used to be bustling with life
and it's got buildings and
infrastructure but now it's an
opportunity zone because the industry
left we could save money we could have
available uh resources and internet find
a bunch of towns just like that the
problem no good airports so bringing
people in would be impossible so then we
find this area basically which is the
compromise where we're close enough to
an airport but kind of far away but this
facility is still in maryland so it kind
of sucks but there is that i mean i love
this idea of like revitalizing a dead
town there's a there was like a town in
an entire town in connecticut i think i
saw like a year or so ago
the entire town was for sale wow
um talks about this i don't want to live
in connecticut
but megan mccain talks about this on
instagram a lot she's like you know
let's let's create a new place to live
we'll just all go move there and there's
something to that idea of like
just everybody just go to some town and
turn it into a place where you want to
be like all these solar panels on every
roof you don't need a central electric
grid or whatever it's going to be
awesome you know that could be your town
well so uh we're we're planning this in
a different town so we're real new to
trucker
we could get like some light rail going
that'd be great yeah you you think we're
joking i'm not joking no i'm not joking
this is and this is i need a place to
live so let's
build one no no we're we we've been
planning it for the past couple of weeks
nice so we need um a bigger production
facility this this place we're in right
now can host a few of the shows we're
doing but we've got so much happening
and so many people that we're like okay
we need a another building we need
another space because we we don't have
the offices for this place i love how
the media is like gimbal bought an eight
bedroom mansion it's like yeah we rent
out half of it for production and the
other half is basically a green room
essentially where people are like
working plus why can't you have whatever
you want
like have your big house if you want
well sure sure but what i mean is they
try to make it seem like the purpose of
the house is like
we're all we're all just like we have a
theater room and a game room and a
bowling room and it's like well we have
an office in office an office an office
an office a studio studio so we need
another building so we can actually
alleviate some of that pressure so that
you can have the bowling room yeah game
room yes actually i mean we do have
skate parking two lanes which is awesome
right yeah i mean boy fair so here's the
plan we were i was looking for these
these places in west virginia where we
would just start building something
because it's it's actually surprisingly
not that expensive if you're building
just like a standard like office unit
kind of building
and uh i we we went to
i forgot where we were going i remember
we were going to the mall or something
and we took the scenic route and we
drove through a bunch of these small
towns in west virginia that were just
nothing like they're just little houses
and then i was like a lot of these
places are for sale for cheap they need
to work to fix them up
but why bother trying to build this
massive unit and get utilities installed
and all that stuff when we could
literally buy like three of these houses
for the same price and then have twice
as much space as we normally would we
wouldn't have the acreage but we'd have
a decent amount of acreage and then we
actually just have a little urban hub
like well suburban hub where we have
like that building oh yeah that's where
they do video editing that building is
where they do the game design and so
then you have a little town instead of a
building right i think that would be
epic
that sounds really badass
it sounds way better than going to
austin with a bunch of hollywood
celebrities who are just like vomiting
up faux activism and who have absolutely
no principles yeah yeah and then you're
in west virginia which is the second
reddest state in the country
you know the funny thing is though i'll
come like i'm i'm in all right
bring your friends we'll bring the post
millennial to the new town who will be
like the resident newspaper great yeah
this is the funniest thing though check
it out
i've uh i've long maintained this even
going back to the days of like ron paul
because i don't completely agree with
ron paul's conservative positions in a
lot of ways but i do agree with his
libertarian positions of like leave me
alone i'm like i like that see the issue
is
if you're a true left libertarian you're
better off
voting for and supporting right
libertarians real ones the problem with
like the libertarian party is they're
all kind of like out of their mind
except for
now you've got you know dave smith and
these caucus guys who are pretty savvy
and on the level
but here's the thing there's no
situation by which you can vote in the
modern system left libertarians and
actually get a cooperative system that
you want
but if you have in a ron paul style
government of limited government then
you and your friends can be free to get
together and do what you want to do
without being oppressed by outside
forces which really should be you know
that's that's americanism that's like
what that is it's an individualistic
perspective what we have on the left
these days is so much but it's about um
you know these principles that they they
tout these principles of compassion and
whatever else but there's literally
nothing that they wouldn't sacrifice for
this mythological conception of the
greater good we were we were talking
about this with with uh vosh i think
this was on the bonus segment because i
i didn't talk as much on the bonus
segment we argued a little bit more and
uh
i think charlie had brought this up
charlie creek breaths up and then i
agree that basically
there's there's no real good way to
scale left libertarianism
because the idea of libertarian
socialism eventually becomes
authoritarian because there's no way to
enforce once the lines of communication
go six degrees of kevin bacon then
you're forcing people to do things they
don't want to do it's it's an impossible
thing to scale all governments probably
become authoritarian right well right
libertarianism to a certain extent
maybe not and i don't mean far right
like laissez-faire capitalism i mean
like leaning more towards free
enterprise with light regulation like
very light then you'll end up with
people choosing where they want to live
buying what they want to buy it's it's
negotiated it's trade but you got
corporate authoritarianism in that right
that's why i said let regulation so you
have you have the means by which the
people can still cooperate to stop the
centralization of power and so here's
what i'm saying if there is a left
libertarian system
how does it expand to actually encompass
and guarantee your rights in a large
space where you're hundreds of miles
away from somebody else you need like
isolated pockets of it that can
co-interoperate
but so the issue then is
there's not so if you if you had a
government that was left libertarian
that is encompa encompassing the entire
state
you then have people in the northwest
part of the state saying i don't agree
with the southeast is imposing on us and
now you are getting into
authoritarianism it's not necessarily
that it is authoritarian it's that
people are not going to start fighting
and it's hard to have a cohesive system
if the system itself is right
libertarian then you can be like us here
up in the northwest we operate on the
left libertarian principle of
libertarian socialism if you want to
move here here are the rules if you're
not that's fine you can go and do your
own thing and then everyone agrees and
they all work together and they can
share their vegetables without using
money and then the right libertarian
people is the overarching system where
it says we're going to leave you all
alone
unless there's the non-aggression
principle and unless you've got the
currency and the negotiating skills you
can't come in and screw with these
people then on your own little hippie
farm you can do whatever you want
that i think works out pretty great
maybe unless except that it's a very
similar type of thing right because you
still then have a
sort of group ideology that rules
everything and individuals are not
permitted to go against that group
ideology but like in a small farm
i don't know like if i sort of like
type of thing i mean if it's your farm
right and it's like your actual farm
then i wouldn't move there if i didn't
want to go along with your thing but
like then we're also you know cults do
that too like did you guys see that
netflix documentary about uh that little
town in oregon that was taken over by
this weird cult it was like no
wow weird like public sex cult thing it
was very it's very interesting it's
weird
i'm saying there there's there's one
very famous community but they pushed
out all of the people who lived there
originally so the people who lived there
originally had this sort of they were
just like doing whatever you know they
were mostly older folks uh retired there
was like a little cafe or whatever so
these cold people moved in they all
started wearing the exact same outfits
all the time and they basically ran for
city government and they pushed out the
people who were there and they took over
the town right that's a that's when you
get an authoritarianism that's why i'm
saying left libertarianism doesn't scale
it eventually just becomes authoritarian
so the the the true ideal of left
libertarianism would be like a farm
with like a bunch of hippies hanging out
and they're friends with each other and
their family or whatever
i get a little utopian
there's a very famous one that's uh got
a hundred
a hundred person capacity and people
apply and then they say here are the
rules and then they come in and they
stay as long as they want and when
they're done they leave and then it
opens up a position for someone else
somebody else can come in yeah so it ca
it's capped at 100. and everyone knows
the rules and everyone agrees and they
you know arbitrate disputes between
people but for the most part it is
a cooperative and the people with
seniority are the ones who
basically say like okay if you're new
here we're going to protect the people
who are here but people rotate
interesting you get bigger than that and
it start you start
swallowing up other people's
jurisdictions and then it just becomes
why can't we have why can't we have a
city that uh respects people's
individual liberties and doesn't
capitulate to authoritarianism
like maybe a nice nice big city with
some because people don't want to work
that's that's probably it so i think i'm
so happy to work i'm so grateful to have
a job all the time i'm like yeah i have
a job but look at what we're looking
look at what we're seeing now with the
current the current trends in in
business the labor shortage
i i saw somebody post uh somebody posted
a meme and they were like it was it was
two two stands like you know kiosks and
one had a huge line of people and the
other didn't and the huge line of people
said 17 an hour and the other kiosk said
minimum wage and then they they
commented like maybe if these businesses
paid better wages people would want to
work there and i say that's not true the
problem is that they're not paying
enough it's the government's paying them
for nothing well that's what the
president said the president basically
told there was like a one of those
stupid town hall things on cnn and a
business owner was like hey i can't get
anyone to come work at my restaurant and
biden was basically like maybe you
should pay more
so you guys like oh yeah i should i
should pay more with like restrictions
and you know how is he supposed to make
any money if he can't get anyone to work
there so it's it's obvious
if you're paying someone 16 bucks an
hour not to work that means they can
literally sit there staring at all or
play video games
if someone comes and says 17 an hour to
work 40 hours you'd be like you're
paying me a dollar an hour yeah i don't
want to do that because this because
zero has now become 16 bucks an hour
right the interesting thing about this
is that people will accept the 300 bonus
check until 300 is literally worth
nothing because think about it let's say
right now the government's like okay 300
per week is a bonus and you're thinking
okay 300 bucks that can buy me enough
groceries for about a week inflation
hits because they're mass printing of
money without any resources being
produced so within a couple of weeks or
a month now you're you're like okay 300
bucks can get me about 65 of the way
through the week in terms of groceries
i'll take it's free right
that carries on until eventually you're
like 300 bucks it's a free cheeseburger
right i'll take a free cheeseburger
right no matter what happens it's just
it's free something no matter how much
or how little is it is a free something
so until 300 becomes worth zero people
will never give up free money granted a
free cheeseburger you'll still have to
get a job then but then we're still
driving hyperinflation how big the
cheeseburger is but yeah i mean i think
also part of the devaluing of work and
devaluing the worth at work ethic
is part of our culture that devalues
life
we devalue the individual we say you
know you're not worth anything unless
you're famous you're not worth anything
unless you're rich or any of these other
things you know
be driven by your pleasure principles
don't be driven by uh
interest and responsibility and you know
stewarding families or any of this you
know we're
the the message that we get is to like
it's idiocracy right it's my judge's
ideologies like sit around jerk off eat
cheeseburgers and don't care about
yourself don't care about
other human beings don't care about your
own
worth if aliens ever come to earth
they will shake hands with humans not
because they overcame nuclear weapons
but because we overcame the xbox that's
a i can't remember that what that quote
is from it's a little bit old because
xboxes are a little bit old yeah well no
i mean everyone plays playstation right
that's the real issue no anyway the
point is
uh
video games are you shilling for
microsoft right now no i'm mocking them
for being you know less popular
video games trigger you know dopamine
right it's replaced our actual goals and
drives and desires we are addicted to
not doing
we're not doing substantive things i've
been feeling nihilistic lately and it's
partly i think and i'm kind of trying to
locate why what i've come to is i keep
wanting to solve the world's problems in
it's in this lifetime i feel like i can
and i'm going if i don't then i've
failed and it's driving me insane
because it's such a big
problem and group think and herd
mentality and i realize or at least i'm
thinking maybe we're just planting the
seeds of the trees we'll never see
with yeah well of course it's a it's a
long game it's a long project but also
isn't the project have a lot to do with
doesn't the project have a lot to do
with um
how we interact with each other in a
personal level how we go about our daily
lives being kind to each other is so
meaningful
you know like
i don't think that that can be
overestimated i sound dumb and
pollyanna-ish you know and i've been
accused of pollyannaism before polyanism
where you're just like hopelessly
optimistic despite uh
but i do think that i do think that the
what really matters in life are the
the kind moments that we have with one
another i think that's what
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel
youtube.comcast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time